si tuviera noches para ti a pesar que en
este momento ecuador se mantiene en
completa tranquilidad como parte del
silencio electoral por lo menos en la
ciudad de quito
existe mucha movilización por parte de
los ciudadanos a pesar de estar en un
rebrote de la pandemia pero hay un dato
particularmente importante que es bueno
tomar en cuenta es que inclusive la
policía nacional ha emitido una alerta
de posibles desmanes durante las
votaciones y los escrutinios por ello ha
reforzado inclusive la seguridad
desplegado a más de 45 mil funcionarios
policiales y 37 mil funcionarios de la
guardia en nacional para garantizar el
orden durante los comicios el día 11 de
abril por lo pronto el consejo nacional
electoral
última detalle y realiza reuniones
conmovedores internacionales
específicamente se ha informado que se
reúne con la misión electoral de la oea
es esta es una de las que tiene mayor
asistencia son 77 veedores
internacionales desplegados en todo el
país incluido las de 293 veedores
internacionales que agrupan
todas las misiones electorales en este
país y de igual forma también continúa
en la tranquilidad a la espera de la
realizar los comicios
gustavo en los candidatos ya cerraron
sus campañas ya no pueden hacer
proselitismo ni hablar de sus propuestas
de campaña pero qué hicieron los
candidatos el día de hoy qué agenda
tenían
específicamente en cuanto a la
realización de la campaña no se ha
emitido ningún tipo de información por
ninguno de los dos equipos de los ambos
candidatos finalistas lo que sí sucede
en este momento es continuar una guerra
se encuentra encuesta existen
pronunciamientos por parte de los
equipos de campañas en las redes
sociales debe tomar en cuenta que las
redes sociales no son reguladas por
parte de la normativa electoral lo que
sí hay son unas publicaciones de
encuestas que emiten en tendencias a
favor de uno u otro candidato que a
pesar que la normativa electoral no rige
para las caras internacionales vamos a
respetar porque inclusive ellos están
ofreciendo tendencias que benefician a
uno de los dos candidatos sólo sucede en
las redes sociales pero no se está
realizando ningún evento de campaña
oficial